i'm curious is there uh the do you have
a worst or best christmas present you've
ever received
oh god the the best one i received i
i feel like the younger you were the
better your christmas presents 100
dude back when i could like just get
like a bunch of shitty toys that lasted
10 minutes
like what the probably best christmas
gift i ever got was i got a game boy
advance
oh [ __ ] yeah when i was like five and i
played like the shitty like kirby port
that was like the snes game which i
found out ages ago it was like five
dollar game i was just like
this is amazing father thank you yeah
probably the best present i've ever got
was an n64 and i
i think it was more the experience
around it because uh so i was at my
cousin's house and
i opened it like remember when game
consoles were like
the gods here of anything you could ever
get oh yeah like no gift could compare
yeah
yeah you know your parents loved you
when they got you a game personally
it's like i feel truly loved because
thank you mother and father i remember
my parents got me when i was i don't
know i don't know when that came out you
know when the wii was like impossible to
get yeah like 2005 or something yeah
and it was just impossible to get well
they were like all sold out in the uk
but my dad worked in germany for like
most of my life
so when he came back for christmas he
brought me it and i was like holy holy
[ __ ] how did you get a wii
and then as we went to plug in on
christmas day yeah i couldn't [ __ ]
plug it in because he had the german
block and then because my dad obviously
just forgot to buy one
right and i remember booting it up and
it being like ashton
and then
[Music]
or something i'm like what is this dad
dad that helped me and my dad can't
[ __ ] speak german so he was like i
don't know son what are we doing
i don't know like i [ __ ] had wii
sports but like
and there's some other sports i had some
game and the title was
german i remember just i was like so
[ __ ] confused as a kid i was like
what the [ __ ]
is this i think i got the wii for
christmas as well actually now i think
about it [ __ ] was born man yeah
but you know what ended up happening
because it was when we sports was like
insane
the the the day we got up working which
was next day we we sport i couldn't
[ __ ] play it because all my [ __ ]
like older relatives are playing like
wee bowling drunk
when am i going to play zelda what the
[ __ ] this is my gift what the [ __ ]
and yeah no because i just remember my
my like one of my best memories of the
n64 was just the first time i boost up
goldeneye with my cousins and it was i
think that was my first proper like
multiplayer experience because i'm like
whoa four people can play at the same
time
and we can play together and at that
time like that was [ __ ] mind-blowing
because the the best poor player game
back then was probably like [ __ ]
bomberman
or something like that mario party maybe
no because mario
wasn't out there it wasn't no yeah
because the first one was on n64 yeah
yeah
um i remember we stayed up till like 4
00 a.m which back when i was a kid was
like
my mind is always like not sleeping for
two days yeah yeah i might as well have
been up before
but if you get a brand new game console
man those those endorphins are firing
off oh yeah
oh my god dude i don't really get that
anymore because you can afford
everything now yeah i guess so right
it's like doing a pint of cocaine like
seeing the ps like seeing the ps5 i'm
like i know if i get it i'll play like
demon souls and be like yeah i mean sure
like yeah
yeah because the jump isn't that
significant ps4 games can load twenty
percent faster now yeah
going from like a snes to an n64 it's
like whoa
you [ __ ] kidding me i can walk in any
direction what
up is forward what is this analog stick
oh my god the cancer that is the [ __ ]
n64 controller
i look at i look at that thing now i
look at that thing now and i'm just like
how did anyone think this was a good
idea i love picking it up still i'm
being like god damn you ugly son of a
[ __ ]
i i i feel it again and i put my thumb
on like the analog stick and i'm just
like
how is it this [ __ ] hard like this is
designed to give blistered how did this
pass the ergonomics test yeah the moment
i like put the thing like put my thumb
on the joystick my
palm just starts to hurt i'm just like
the memories of blistered palms doing
[ __ ] this on my
party too yeah you could get gloves from
uh nintendo yeah they would say because
they lost a lawsuit
yeah because mario party won because
yeah arm injuries yes
oh yeah yeah my partner destroyed him
i believe that doesn't say yeah i i just
assumed like the design team and
nintendo the first day on the job they
just took like an ergonomics book and
just set on fire
okay we're designing the n64 controller
now guys is it fun
put it in man i remember as well that
same christmas when we got the wii
my older brother got like uh not the
death star what's the other big
battleship in star wars the one that's
like uh [ __ ]
like that all the the yeah something
like that
and then he built it all and for some
reason had the amazing idea to put it
near the tv in front of where we were
with the wii and yeah i'm sure you can
imagine what happened
oh yeah [ __ ] hit the roof someone did
the bowling through
it slammed the roof smashed down and
destroyed this thing
did he spend like eight hours building
it was so
funny i'll never forget that [ __ ]
watching watching my dad playing wii
sports is probably the funniest thing
i've ever seen in my life because
boomers get so into it oh dude like he
was so
into [ __ ] wii boxing as well it's
like of all
of all the sports ones it was the
[ __ ] joke
and oh my god just watching my dad just
[ __ ] doing this for like two hours
it's just oh
so funny